und jetzt lassen wir uns mal über ein
ganz eigenes thema sprechen liebe
zuschauer kleinkriminalität sekunden ich
habe mich verlesen klaren kriminalität
kleinen fehler kleinkriminalität
dauerthema in deutschen medien nicht
ganz zu unrecht vor allem in nordrhein
westfalen und in berlin gibt es
kriminell aktive großfamilien mit
arabischen wurzeln und bis zu 500
mitgliedern
ja da geht es um drogenhandel
körperverletzung aber auch um
spektakuläre fälle wie die geklaute
riesen goldmünze aus dem bode museum in
berlin wo ist dir eigentlich und gefragt
was sagen sie zu prozessen machen warum
sind so viele mitglieder ihrer partei an
ihr seid kriminelle diese premiere ist
seit die kriminellen wissen mit der
goldmünzen mit der goldmünze jetzt
bestimmt bei euch hier unten im
anschwingen unten im arsch des typen von
spiegel tv
da hätte ich dich nachgeguckt muss ich
vielleicht stimmt krimineller energie
hat übrigens nichts mit ethnien oder
herkunft zu tun
es waren deutsche familien clans wie die
px und die quandts die uns vorsätzlich
jahrelang dreckige diesel verdikt haben
oder hier die legendären aldi brüder
wir haben deutschland damals eiskalt
unter sich aufgeteilt aldi nord und aldi
süd ja ist so manche klaren zusammen
schutzgeld andere illegale parteispenden
es ist klar diese klaren gangster aus
dem libanon sind schon ein sehr
spezieller verein in einigen familien
ist das besonders ausgeprägt und die
kriminalität unter diesen leuten ist
etwas was zum familienleben gehört ja
jede familie hat halt ihre eigenen
rituale manche rauben geldtransporter
aus wir sind sonntags immer zur oma
gefahren
teil des problems ist natürlich dass
viele clan-mitglieder nur geduldet war
das heißt die durften nicht arbeiten
daraus lernen wir entweder abschieben
oder den leuten eine perspektive geben
gleichzeitig werden gut integrierte
flüchtlinge aus der lehre heraus
abgeschoben wie soll man das dem bürger
noch erklären oder fälle wie den hier
kriminaltechniker finden eine dna spur
die zu abdul madschid führt doch der
wird zwei jahre später freigesprochen
grund daher die ganze familie kriminell
ist hätte die kabeltrommel auch einer
der brüder von zu hause mitbringen
können gesetzeslage wenn alle kriminell
sind kannst du nichts machen
ja es braucht wohl härtere urteile aber
auch mehr geld für polizei und ganz
wichtig sozialarbeit der sport zum
beispiel sport ist immer gut für
integration
bitte nicht immer ach so in oer
erkenschwick zum beispiel stellen
clan-mitglieder eine ganze
fußballmannschaft elf spieler ein name
manchmal entscheiden hier nicht
spielzüge sondern schläge an den ersten
fc blutgrätsche
jogi du suchst doch noch spieler
allerdings allerdings wird langsam
besser es werden immer mehr klaren
immobilien beschlagnahmt und wer sich
als hartz 4 empfänger zwei porsche kauft
muss erklären wo das geld herkommt kurz
gesagt unser rechtsstaat ist in sachen
clans aufgewacht nach nur 30 jahren ja
in jedem fall ein echtes aufreger thema
jetzt reagiert sogar mein sender mit
einem eigenen thementag dem zdf
thementag plans ganz toll
schon morgens geht's los mit löwen clan
peter lustig zeigt den kindern wie man
christmas kopf im anschluss die krasse
soziale streiche von bibi blocksberg
unsere lieblings hexe vermöbelt die
bullen
danach geht es weiter mit baris
illegales der zdf fehler horst lichter
hilft geklaute goldmünzen in bargeld zu
verwandeln cool und direkt nach dem
beute journal das leider ausfällt weil
alle kameras geklaut sind wird's
romantisch bei rosamunde pilcher es war
liebe du bastard der zdf thementag klar
ins top unterhaltung für die ganzen
kleinen kriminelle großfamilien
montag auch beim letzten montag bei hart
aber fair leider ist der ganze gangsters
teil längst in der deutschen popkultur
angekommen inzwischen reden sogar
deutsche oberschicht kinder wie
möchtegern verbrechern bruder
ich muss nach hause gegen mutter richtig
schwer liegt vielleicht auch am erfolg
von gut gemachten serien wie vier blocks
[Musik]
gehört jetzt keiner kommt an uns vorbei
glückwunsch vier blogs oder foren blogs
keine heilung jemand seine echt gute
serie
allerdings wird das klaren leben da
schon ein bischen glorifiziert was man
so hört fühlen sich die echten gangster
hervorragend porträtiert aber klar wenn
so eine tv show wie die erfolg hat und
preise kriegt dann gibt es natürlich
ganz schnell wer billige nachahmer er
war ein ganz normaler spießer er hat
steuern gezahlt und immer rechtzeitig
laub geharkt wegen der nachbarn
aber dann hatte er plötzlich die
schnauze voll
ich habe plötzlich die schnauze voll ich
werde jetzt auch denkst du scheiß auf
das laub
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von den machern von vier blogs kommt
jetzt vier reihenhäuser in berlin
zehlendorf genau ihre matches
ich bin oberhaupt des humboldt clans war
schwer und das ganze gebiet wollen nach
vorne wir unser zaun anfängt bis da
drüben zum waldorfkindergarten bruder
was geht da will man sieht sich
natürlich noch zu einem klaren väter und
geschwister bin ein einzelkind wohnen
noch bei mutti
nur weiß ich was auf deine mutter
zehlendorf plötzlich ein hotspot des
verbrechens illegale fahrradrennen
völlig falsche mülltrennung und immer
wieder vorsätzlich bei rot über die
ampel gehen
war neulich schon in neukölln und damit
den ganzen anderen klaren zu wissen
hier kommt der neue barbie entschuldigen
sie ich wollte mich mal grundsätzlich
über drogenhandel informieren wo bekommt
man diese drogen und wie werden da die
arbeitszeiten
ach ja und ist man der
krankenversicherer ja wie gesagt
neukölln es später an
aber hier im blog habe ich das sagen wir
sind alle es gibt es direkt bei schering
gekrankt mach das weg sehr gut dann
nicht weil ich das eben
eine [ __ ] vier reihenhäuser in
berlin zehlendorf demnächst bei arte
[Musik]
[Applaus]